thanks to audible for keeping legal
eagle in the air
don't call me Allah and the bailiff
tackled them Heil illegals it's time to
think like a lawyer today we are
covering one of my all-time favorite
legal dramas it is the Rainmaker
starring Matt Damon this I think will be
the first time I have seen this movie
since becoming a lawyer I think it has
been over 10 years since I've seen this
movie I'm nervous I'm really hoping it
stands up to the test of time I remember
it being really good so of course be
sure to comment in the form of an
objection which I will either sustain or
overrule and stick around until the end
of the video where i give the Rainmaker
a grade for legal realism so without
further ado let's dig in to the
Rainmaker well before we can file the
claim I need all three of you to sign
this what is daddy coming in well he
said he wasn't some days he comes in at
some days you don't well this is a
contract what's in it all unusual its
standard language and it basically says
it y'all hire us to be your attorneys
and and we take care of the case for you
we handle any expenses if we might have
and and then we get one-third of any
recovery alright so this is what's
called a retention agreement which is
something you rarely see in the movies
but it is something that is absolutely
ethically required to be able to
actually represent people it lays out
the terms of your engagement and it lays
out the terms of your compensation as
well and the contract that is being
signed here is a fairly standard one for
plaintiffs working on contingency the
plaintiffs attorneys will pay for the
costs which can sometimes be very very
expensive in terms of filing fees and
experts and deposition costs and then if
there is any recovery at the end the
plaintiffs attorneys will get one-third
- say 40% of what is recovered you might
say that that is a lot of money
especially when your
dealing with thousands or millions of
dollars but the plaintiffs attorneys
take on a huge amount of risk they might
be out tens or hundreds of thousands of
dollars or thousands of man-hours to
work up these cases with no guarantee
that they're going to get anything so
that is the trade-off when you're
dealing with contingency work well why
does it take two pages to say all that
yeah no lawyers man they're the worst
Donny ray has leukemia and his medical
insurance denied him a bone-marrow
transplant which would have provided
relief to his condition that's the point
of this lawsuit well the record my name
is Leo F Drummond of Tinley bridge
counsel for great benefit and I say if
this young man has passed the bar exam
Your Honor let him argue the case we
welcome him to big-time litigation you
have no objection mr. Drummond if it
please the court I would be honored to
introduce mr. Baylor to the practice of
law in the great state of Tennessee
judge you can give me off right now now
I'll be pleased to stand for that's
actually not just a formality usually in
order to stand for the oath of office
you have to be sponsored by a practicing
attorney this is such a good scene
because you have this big firm lawyer
who knows he's getting a huge advantage
by getting this greenhorn attorney and
rather than getting a continuance or
dealing with another more seasoned
attorney he is offering to sponsor this
young man to take the oath of office so
that he can you know litigate against
someone that doesn't know what they're
doing
kudos to John Grisham for writing this
and kudos to Francis Ford Coppola for
the way that they staged it's it's so
good mr. Drummond
you've objected to the fast tracking of
this case what's the problem
well your honor this issue has already
been ruled upon by Judge Hale the
preparations required fast pecking the
case
place undue burden on the on both
parties every nonsense nice let me ask
you something mr. Drummond as a defense
lawyer if you ever agreed to the
fast-tracking of a lawsuit well Your
Honor I believe I have fine give me the
name of the case and the court it was in
fast-tracking by the way is a thing that
exists in lots of different
jurisdictions it doesn't have a
consistent meaning it depends on what
particular court you're in but often
cases will have different tracks based
on how complex they are and the need for
any due process here and given that
there is a young man who is dying of
leukemia here you can imagine that fast
tracking would be very very important to
make sure that all the necessary
discovery is taken before he passes away
about next Thursday afternoon great for
me your honor I'm sorry that's the week
from today
I believe I'm out of town yes I am out
of town Thursday the deposition is set
for next Thursday afternoon at 2:00 p.m.
sorry if it inconveniences the defense
god knows there's nothing you guys to
handle it now what's next so I have
actually seen a judge make a statement
almost identical to that it is one of
the disadvantages of showing up to court
with the whole army of attorneys
sometimes I've been on the side of the
army and sometimes I've been on the side
of just one person but when you show up
with multiple people in court and you
claim that your schedule doesn't allow
you to participate in certain things the
judge will just look at all of the other
people that are at counsel table and say
well if you're not available then one of
these other people will be available to
take care of it so that's one of the
issues when you
with a whole bunch of other co-counsel
tom looking at a team of lawyers who are
pulling down $1,000 an hour and I hate
them from their lofty perch pissing down
on the whole justice system that disdain
I used to hate them because I wasn't
good enough for them now I hate them for
who they represent and what they
represent hope the dogs didn't start so
it would be very unusual to hold a
deposition outside just because you know
you're in the elements and it's hard to
do but it would not be unusual at all to
have a whole bunch of attorneys on both
sides to participate in one of these
central depositions in the case when
you're dealing with toxic torts where
you have lots of lots of different
companies and they all have counsel you
want to have 30 people in a room
participating in the deposition
hey Donna right you've already met judge
kipler you would also definitely want to
record the deposition testimony with a
video camera as they are doing here
there is an added cost of course but it
is so important to be able to see the
intonation and the facial expressions of
these important witnesses when they're
giving their deposition testimony what
is really really unusual here is that
the judge is participating in the
deposition sort of as an observer often
you have discovery disputes that happen
during the deposition where you
threatened to call up the judge to
adjudicate the the matter so that you
don't have to stop a deposition and pick
it up days later I guess it could be the
case where the judge just wants to stick
it to the other side so the judge
actually participates in the deposition
itself I have never seen that but it
directly could happen youngberry better
time to hit this for some coffee
Tyler jack underhall rudy banyez always
always a hungry lawyer all these boss
claims under there must be a hundred
years of legal experience gathered
around the table my staff has flunked
the bar exam six times Rudy don't be
intimidated by all these bars on this
side of the table I guarantee you get
him on a golf course it won't like a
cheap suit jon voight plays such a great
pompous big law attorney he's just
taking up all the air in the room and
he's trying to dominate his opposing
counsel I was just playing such a jerk
and it's perfect God that is exactly
what these older big firm attorneys are
likely to do I think maybe it's
appropriate to start with the corporate
designee jack on the hole here yeah I
don't think so
I beg your pardon well you heard me I
want to start with Jack Elam and
I think it's best we start with mr. on
the hall all due respect mr. Drummond
this is my deposition I'm gonna call
these witnesses in the order in which I
see fit so I'd like to start with
checking the magic maybe we should just
go call the judge and it's a great
threat perfectly reasonable - you can do
that pugilistic this time in the morning
I'm not gonna mean to be pugilistic
they're simply having a little problem
with the jakela magic this Polish woman
what sort of problem polish for me Jesus
she doesn't work you anymore
what's your fire she reside she resigned
um well where is she now
well she is no longer working for our
client and we can't produce as a witness
so let's move along that's true if the
employee is no longer with the
corporation the corporation is under no
duty to produce that person for a
deposition but you can bet that there
was probably some shenanigans that led
to that particular person no longer
working at this company this bugging
devices yeah
medium-grade circuitry the weak
transmitter
from manufactory Czechoslovakia I don't
think the cops are the fails in places
somebody else is listening ' listen
I got a pretty good idea so Rudy's
office got bugged for a long time I
thought that would be completely
unrealistic but lately there have been
some law firms that have gotten in
really hot water
maybe not for bugging their opponents
but for doing some really shady things
for example David Boies hiring an
Israeli security firm on behalf of
Harvey Weinstein nowadays what used to
be something that would only be seen in
fiction is actually becoming more
realistic that's that's a sorry state
that we live in the judge gave us the
names of 92 potential jurors we
investigated their backgrounds and we
rated them with plus or minus numbers
what any direct contact would of course
be a serious offence what are we doing
we're gonna do this thing just do what I
say okay hello yeah Rudy Baylor please
this is Billy Porter you stopped by the
shop today
yes mr. Porter
well what do you want yes well it's
about the trial you know the one you got
is this legal of course it's legal mr.
Porter just just don't go tell me yeah
so this point the opposing counsel has
bugged Rudy's phone and listened to the
false information of him pretending to
talk to one of the jury members and so
he's going to try to avoid ear the jury
and elicit information about this jury
tampering that actually didn't happen
fairly brilliant way to screw with
opposing counsel did you mr. Porter or
did you not have a phone conversation a
few days ago with mr. Rudy Baylor
hell no I thought you gonna give me an
honest answer I gave you an honest
answer are you sure mr. Porter I'm damn
sure mr. Porter in a courthouse in a
courthouse in the United States
house of justice state of Tennessee I
say you did not provide an honest answer
don't call me a liar your and the
bailiff tackled them Billy Porter you
are excused from the jury yeah seems
like a good reason to dismiss a jerk
Jana I move to dismiss a tie patty got
denied so Rudy fed them false
information the defense counsel bought
it hook line and sinker and they made a
fool of themselves and now the jury
probably hates defense counsel so great
job by Rudy under the odd circumstances
of having his office and phone bugged by
opposing counsel I don't know if that's
the right tactic to have taken if he had
taken that information to the judge
Leo Drummond the defense counsel could
have been disbarred and that would
really have thrown a wrench into the
entire defense please state your name
for the record mrs. Marvin black now
mrs. black you are the mother of Donny
ray black who recently died of acute my
lytic leukemia because a defendant great
engagement leading yep yeah common
mistake that lawyers make especially on
direct examination is that they try to
fit too much into the question instead
of just letting the witness tell their
story on direct examination the lawyers
should just disappear into the
background you're just facilitating the
testimony and you're asking open-ended
questions like what happened how did
that make you feel what happened next
can you explain that and he is asking
very leading questions you shouldn't do
that you must be stupid stupid
sincerely Everett left Kim vice
president Klein's department
read it again objection
repetitious your honor it's a sticker
it's not allowed to do that I tender the
witness mr. Drummond please remove that
exhibit oh man that is that is so great
I have I've actually never seen this in
a movie before it is a common trial
tactic too when you have a demonstrative
whether it is a projector or a you know
a physical blow up of a document to
leave them up for as long as you
possibly can to have the greatest effect
on the jury the experienced trial lawyer
the first thing he does before he begins
his cross-examination is he tells the
other side to take down his
demonstrative that is possibly the
greatest trial detail I think I have
ever seen in a movie it's just it's
perfect I need to speak the beer I know
can you connect me right up
hello are you here hello I'm here I'm
there so in the book version deck
schifflet actually knows where bruiser
put all of his illegal money which is a
difference between the movie and the
book which I listen to love Ruby cage so
that's really funny because what they
are talking about is the case citation
for a case that apparently has some good
authority on using stolen evidence he
said you could find it in 650 something
Southwest second and then he didn't give
a pin sight but what he is talking about
is the volume itself the the book of the
compendium of cases all the reported
cases 650 something in the southwest 2nd
reporter which is absolutely the right
reporter where you will find all of
these cases that's another thing that
you rarely see in legal movies is the
correct nomenclature for finding a case
citation this is the claims manual that
was given to me by Jackie as a magic
objection y'all stolen work papers
inadmissible you rule on this sustained
maybe broke
I thought this matter is already settled
you your honor I'm just this morning
found a case that is controlled in this
factual situation if you just take a
look at this room
it's Club Ruby versus carmine de Soto
it's copy for your honor everyone for
mr. Drummond number 585 Southwest second
date for thirty-one argued by Busey
I'm J Lyman stone and he chose very
clearly that stolen documents are in
fact admissible if the lawyers played no
part there when according to these hit
notes this case will overrule your
objection yeah so the trial court is not
bound by its own prior rulings it can
revisit its rulings for the most part
this is a great example of what's called
a pocket brief where you will either
take the case or write a quick argument
write it down so that you can provide it
to the judge when the need arises and he
here he has provided this case to the
judge to revisit the prior decision on
stolen work product and what the judge
mentions this is such a great detail to
the judge didn't read the actual full
case but he read what he called head
notes head notes are the summaries that
the case database is put at the top of
the case so you don't have to read the
entire case itself it summarizes the
relevant law such attention to detail
it's incredible
this case will overrule your objection
sorry leo
but note my strong objection objection
noted
may I approach oh this is another great
detail the stenographer stands up from
her desk
so that she can take down what is being
discussed between the judge and the
counsel even though it's not being
projected over the PA system she is
still taking down the dialogue that's
going on because that has to go in the
record I don't think I've ever seen that
in a legal movie it's it's just it's
perfect
mr. Keeley that is a report from great
benefits own medical commitment which
you chaired would you please read from
line 18
since bone-marrow transplants have
become standard procedure great benefit
would be financially justified and
investing in bone-marrow clinics
approach a witness your honor
you may thank you there you go little
louder
objection your honor repetition oh my
god that's so good I think this was done
on purpose and I think it's to show that
Rudy is sort of becoming a great trial
lawyer if we rewind it back in the prior
scene he moves the microphone away with
the binder he kind of nudges it away
making the microphone a little bit
further away so that when the witness
reads this incredibly damning statement
it's a little low in volume he then
walks back to the witness stand moves
the microphone towards the witness and
asks that the witness read the statement
again because it wasn't picked up the
first time but I think the point there
is to show that he moved it away on
purpose so that he could get around the
normal objection to repetitious
testimony I've seen an attorney
essentially do the exact same thing when
moving the microphone closer to the the
witness so that they can say it more
clearly for the second time to really
hammer home this great evidence this is
just this is amazing it's it's amazing
[Music]
all right that was the Rainmaker one of
my favorite legal movies of all time and
I'm glad to see that it stands up but
now it's time to give the movie a grade
for legal realism
on the one hand we have a very very
realistic trial we have trial tactics
that not only exist in the real world
but this movie captures nuances that
I've just never seen in any other work
of legal fiction on the other side there
are some bits of dramatic license you
have bad lawyers but frankly they're bad
lawyers within the narrative of the
story so they should be behaving badly
so that actually seems to make sense all
in all I think this might be the most
accurate legal drama that I've ever seen
so I'm giving the Rainmaker and a plus I
had no idea was directed by Francis Ford
Coppola it's just beautiful I guess
that's it did you know that John Grisham
says this movie is the best adaptation
of any of his books it's easy to see why
because this movie is fantastic but the
book is almost as good I wanted to see
what the differences were between the
movie and the book so I prepared for
this review by listening to the
Rainmaker on audible audible is great
because you can read no matter what else
you're doing like responding to improper
copyright claims on your YouTube videos
I mean
audible is giving legal eagles like you
a free 30-day trial all you need to do
is go over to audible.com slash legal
eagle click the link in the description
or text legal eagle - 500 500 you can
download any audio book of your choosing
and you'll get two audible originals for
free clicking on the link really helps
out this channel you'd be crazy not to
take that if you liked the Rainmaker by
John Grisham you will love his other
books he is a very prolific writer so
there are over thirty different John
Grisham books available on audible
including his brand-new book The
Reckoning and classics like the firm and
a time to kill so head over to
audible.com slash legal eagle or text
legal eagle - 500 500 do you agree with
my grade absolutely leave your
objections in the comments and check out
this playlist over here with all of my
other real lawyer reactions where I will
see you in court